today's topic is about parametric and
non-parametric tests and let's get
started
why are you interested in this topic you
want to calculate a hypothesis test but
you don't know exactly what the
difference is between a parametric and a
non-parametric test
and you're wondering when to use which
test
if you want to calculate a hypothesis
test you must first check the
assumptions
one of the most common assumptions is
that the data used must show a certain
distribution
usually the normal distribution
simplified we could say that
if your data is normally distributed
parametric tests are used for example
the t test the anova or a pearson
correlation
if your data is not normally distributed
you use a non-parametric test
for example a man with new test or a
spearman correlation
what about the other assumptions
of course you still have to check if
there are further assumptions for the
respective test
but in general there are less
assumptions for non-parametric tests
than for parametric tests
so why then do we need parametric tests
parametric tests are generally more
powerful than non-parametric tests
what does that mean
let's say you have formulated your null
hypothesis which is for example the
salary of men and women does not differ
whether the null hypothesis is rejected
depends on the following things
on the difference in the salary
and also on the sample size
in a parametric test
a smaller difference in the salary
or a smaller sample
is usually sufficient to reject the null
hypothesis
so if possible always use parametric
tests
and now there's still two open topics
first i'll show you what the most common
parametric and non-parametric tests are
and then i will explain to you how you
can easily calculate these tests online
with data tab
usually for the most common parametric
tests
there is always a non-parametric
counterpart if you only have one sample
the parametric test is the simple t-test
and the non-parametric test is the
wilcoxon test for one sample if you have
two dependent samples on one side it is
the paired t-test and on the other side
it is the wilcoxon test
if we look at independent samples it's
the unbeared t-test and the man with new
tests if you don't know exactly what
dependent and independent samples are
just watch my witty about it you can
find the link in the video description
below
if you have more than two independent
samples you use the analysis of variance
or the kraskel wallis test
and finally if you have more than two
dependent groups
you use the anova with repeated measures
or the friedman test
if you want to calculate the correlation
between two variables you can use either
the pearson correlation or the spearman
correlation
you can find the link to this overview
in the video description
if you want to analyze your data by
using data tab
you just visit datadept.net
and you click on the statistics
calculator
then you can copy your data into this
table and click on this tab which says
t-test g-square test anova and so on
let's say that you want to test if there
is a difference between men and women in
the salary
you choose salary as metric variable and
as a nominal variable gender
then automatically a t-test for
independent samples is calculated which
is a parametric test
if you want you can also click here then
a non-parametric test will be calculated
then you can see that the man with new
test is calculated
which is the non-parametric counterpart
to the t-test for independent samples
i hope you liked this video and thank
you for watching
you